reading about you it's always it's
always an element of humor or comedy
even in your mother's funeral I'm a dad
so yeah my mom and dad Trina we were
mucking around anyway
even when them my dad my mum died first
um and it was a long horrible illness it
was uh it was lung cancer it was lung
cancer and it was it was dreadful
I mean the worst Scituate you can
imagine the table and so there was a
certain amount of um you know relief
afterwards she was out of pain and
everything oh oh yeah oh yeah it was it
was anyway it was dribble I remember
yeah it was it was dreadful um but uh
you know when we were organizing the
funeral um the the vicar said to my
brother and tell me something about your
mother what was was and my brother just
mucking around said she was a keen
racist right in the thick of it I can't
without you and I'll put gardening then
and then he gave the vicar the wrong
names of the kids so when he was out we
all laughed my dad's funeral I went
prepared got loads and niece and nephews
and I went and they all died of crying
and I handed out tissues and then they
all started laughing because I've
written things like stop sniveling and
windy and so there and the vicar was
looking at it's laughing during this
funeral we explained to him office but
yeah no that's that's exactly what it
that's exactly what he was for tell me
about Derek Derek is is your new series
yeah uh or your latest series yeah uh
and uh and he's a quite different guy is
very different from David Brent yeah I
office it's funny because I said I still
deal with sort of like you know flawed
characters and then you know I suppose
sort of these are more Outsiders but the
the flaws of the characters are usually
delved into with like people like David
Byrne or Andy Millman um it was their
own fault
you know it was it was ego or ambition
or jealousy whereas with these guys it's
superficial stuff it's like bad
hair a shuffle a funny voice of you know
um so and and that was because I wanted
it to be superficial and something
important could come along and trump it
or which was kindness or compassion or
caring and I put it against her and old
people's home because um I always try
and write about what I know um uh and
about six of my family my mom my sister
my sister-in-law her kids now they
worked in care homes so I sort of had
that backdrop and again they come in
with stories that were really some were
really sad and some are really funny and
some really sweet and I'm not the first
people first watching Derek
they'd say is it a is it a comedy or a
drama I'll wash your life you know it's
a bit of everything isn't it you're
doing a new movie right yeah yeah yeah
called life on the road and it's David
Brent when you're trying to get to the
Derek you're flying on something I have
this very okay I'm sorry Freddy are you
in charge well I used to be good Wailea
cuz they said they would go here we have
some bear is in charge see Freddy you're
a child claim it back I'm so sorry
cos you'll I have another show me do the
intro whip it out we're pretend we're
pretenders though yes yeah okay so we
gotta watch a clip from Derek now yeah
they're laughing they know this is never
gonna cut together
it's gonna cut strengthen your interview
to this clip yeah I know your terrible
trauma and then go the number of shows
I've done well I'm going on to do some
of our comedy or a children's book and
the person before me is just a wonderful
one of the shows I did it was like a
daytime show and they said coming up
next the hilarious Ricky Gervais and his
funny menagerie flanimals but first why
the teenagers self-harm and then as well
either go out it was just a job call it
always happens it always happens to me
you did on purpose take a look take a
look at this this is a clip from there
whoops sorry
the people goes oh don't worry about
dirt ask them but if I drops a baby or
sits on it what sorry isn't
I actually think like that and so sighs
doing a hold it I just think was no wait
no worth my drop it so yeah how are you
you chose not our kids yeah but I've got
I've got loads in these in effuse and
they're having kids now and so husband
where are you good working-class family
I'm a great great uncle yeah well yeah
it's not like it's a like nice yeah yeah
I come over Christmas net through the
pockets and everything coughing on you
I'm always ill after I visited my family
13 kids got ah that's it I lose weight
after Christmas where I've got some sort
of illness no I love I love I love kids
other people's you can play with and go
right us enough um ah so so one final
question because we've been talking
about about her getting married are you
ever getting married because you've been
with the same woman like for yeah 30
years what we are so now he is yeah
eighteen thirty okay yeah but we are
sort of married it's just you know um I
I mean I don't really see the point in a
ceremony you know we we share everything
everything's in both our names it's you
know I don't want our families to me
that wouldn't work
how about Game of Thrones uh yeah we got
loads of toasters we don't need to get
married
Rickie's is great to have you here I
don't know how your mother guess on
thank you thank you is is ricky gervais
[Applause]